[Music]
what's going on out there
it's been a few months since we last
jumped into the chaotic world of for
honor the closed alpha gave me many
enjoyable moments but it also left me
concerned about balancing issues in the
latest build we sat down with three new
characters a new multiplayer mode and
two single-player missions so without
further ado here's my take on how far
honor is shaping up if I had to pick one
thing that didn't work for me back when
I played the closed alpha three months
ago it would be character balancing
light armor characters such as the
Berserker could easily spam light
attacks and run circles around heavy
armored opponents such as the warden and
Raider to the point that during the last
few hours of that alpha no one wanted to
play as a heavy character if the other
team was made out of lights those
balancing issues for the most part have
been addressed in the latest build heavy
characters block more quickly and light
characters run through their stamina a
lot faster preventing them from doing
endless light swinging attacks on other
heroes medium characters such as the
Conqueror have also been given a damage
boost
however this character still has too big
of a tell with a long wind-up of where
he can swing his mace making it too easy
to read his moves there's still
balancing problems that need to be
addressed between light and heavy heroes
but for honor for the most part is
making progress
speaking of characters I got a chance to
play three new additions to the roster
the peacekeeper warlord and the shougo
key the peacekeeper is a fast assassin
hit-and-run kind of hero with a good
attack strength but low defense and
health she's excellent for harassing
enemies and capturing points in a flash
but can be brought down with just three
heavy attacks the warlord is a medium
attack and defensive hero he doesn't
excel in either strength or taking
damage over a long period of time like
other heroes but he does even out the
playing field with good crowd control
and the support role to other players in
need last but not least is Asha goki
one of the most powerful heavy hitters
with just three hits to practically any
character this hero can finish off any
foe he is the slowest moving and
swinging hero making it a tad too easy
to anticipate his moves but comboing him
with a light character Ally and you have
one of the most dangerous duos on the
field all three characters were fun to
play with each one filling a needed role
peacekeepers hit-and-run tactics warlord
playing support and they should go keep
playing the tank
if further balances out the growing
roster in a positive way despite the
fact that each character still needs a
little more fine-tuning
lost the new multiplayer mode I play was
called elimination elimination is a four
verse four with no capture points and no
npc minions pretty much team deathmatch
this mode was a blast allowing us to
take full customized heroes into battle
and brought some the best trash-talking
during my time playing it to
single-player missions were also on hand
raid the Raiders where you play surprise
the Raider class and sabotage where you
play as a peacekeeper the single-player
missions open up an interesting
narrative however as it stands they're
easily forgettable thanks in part to the
combat respawning and repetitive enemies
hurt this experience the most with a
dynasty warrior style set up waves of
dimwit enemies surround you only for
each one of them waiting for their
number to get called up like at the DMV
to get killed one out of every 20 foes
will fight you in a style similar to
what you could find online blocking
countering and unleashing special
attacks helps separate these foes from
the rest of the pack but with them far
and too few in between the drones of
mindless enemies it does nothing but
hurt the experience the narrative is
great so far but the gameplay needs some
heavy work to keep me interested from
start to finish
join us we are with you all in all I had
a great time with four honors
multiplayer the new character classes
new mode and balancing tweaks all played
a role in my enjoyment with the upcoming
release in February of 2017 there's
still a lot of time left for changes and
I'm looking forward to playing it again
are you looking forward to for honor
feel free to share your comments below
and for more on the game keep it here on
GameSpot
[Music]